Trick-or-treat! Fifty-six percent of
Americans in an online Morning Consult poll
say they plan to celebrate Halloween in 2021.
That's up from 42 percent last year when the
pandemic upended people’s plans for the
holiday. Twenty-four percent said they
plan to attend a Halloween party, with young
people more enthusiastic than their elders.
Parents, too, are looking forward to a night out.
In the latest Axios/Ipsos survey, 52 percent of
their said taking their children trick or treating
represented a small risk, 19 percent a moderate
one, and 22 percent no risk. Only 9 percent
said it represented a large risk, down from
21 percent last year. The new responses shouldn’t
surprise us: After a long social drought,
most of us crave the kind of interactions that a
night out can provide, not to mention the candy.
The pandemic took a significant toll on Americans’
overall well being early on, but the country has
been remarkably resilient in the past year and
a half. Most Americans are still being careful,
but they want to have some fun. Boo!
How do you plan to celebrate Halloween?
Let us know in our poll. Also let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.